nous faisons la proposition d'un
prélèvement exceptionnel et non
récurrent sur le patrimoine financier
des ménages des lieux de thé c'est à
dire du 10% supérieur alors je voudrais
tout de suite dissiper les choses aussi
encore des malentendus il s'agit pas de
l'isfaire même si c'est comme ça qu'il a
été popularisé
[Musique]
transition va être difficile parce que
au fond
elle repose sur trois mécanismes
principaux la réalisation du progrès
technique dont j'ai déjà parlé
mais aussi la sobriété et surtout la
substitution de capital des énergies
fossiles la sobriété c'est quelque chose
qui était
pas très très bien défini on a cherché à
donner une définition économique de la
sobriété
qui est la réduction de la consommation
d'énergie qui ne résulte pas de gains
d'efficacité
énergétique donc ça peut couvrir des
mécanismes aussi variés que
le fait de dire on se déplace
différemment se déplacent davantage en
vélo on baisse c'est
la température dans les dans les
logements orange beaucoup moins de
viande etc et tout ça c'est porteurs de
de gains du collectif mais ça n'est pas
nécessairement réducteur de l'utilité
individuelle notre position dans le
rapport c'est qu'il ne faut pas exclure
le recours à l'endettement et que il y a
de mauvaises raisons de s'endetter mais
que le climat n'en fait pas partie et
qu'en particulier le climat
c'est quelque chose qui se caractérise
par le fait que les investissements ont
un taux de retour qui est
assez faible et donc une période
d'amortissement qui est qui est longue
besoin de mettre en cohérence la
programmation des finances publiques et
la programmation
de l'action climatique pour l'instant on
a l'horizon 2024 on a le PLF 2024 mais
on sait pas très bien ce qu'il y a
au-delà je pense que c'est très
important de donner de la visibilité et
de programmer l'ensemble des réflexions
et l'ensemble des actions sur les
finances publiques